[Musique]
bonjour monsieur gagnon bonjour il va en
fait vous interrompre souvent j'ai
beaucoup de questions à vous poser au
cours de la saison la base jardinage
écologique ces sols c'est beaucoup plus
qu'un simple support faut que ce soit
vivant aussi tout à fait aux dépens des
extraits d'une chronique sur le
jardinage qui était diffusé à la semaine
verte par les années 90 et au tournant
de l'an 2000
on y voyait il gagnon qui est un
pionnier de la culture maraîchère sur
petites surfaces
soucieux de la biodiversité avant
l'heure c'est un auteur mais aussi un
des semenciers les plus respectés au
québec avec sa conjointe diane makaay il
a transformé un petit lopin de terre
pour en faire un jardin d'une rare
beauté
nous l'avons rencontré chez lui
[Musique]
l'espèce humaine est la seule espèce à
ma connaissance qui qui peut créer des
paysages pour son propre plaisir de
contemplation on y dans la région de
lanaudière
je prends plaisir à dire qu'on est dans
lanaudière orientale parce qu'au bout de
la paire c'est la mauricie qui commande
c'est un paysage avec du relief
mais les sols sont encore propice à
l'agriculture
on a développé des jardin d'à peu près 1
hectare desjardins qui à l'origine était
en production maraîchère et peu à peu
cette production a évolué à production
semencière jardin d'ornement
au départ c'est à des plantes potagères
mais rapidement vous avez inclut aussi
des fleurs pourquoi en aménageant des
sections avec des fleurs qui ceinturait
nos sections légumière
on a commencé à observer des
interactions ou les auxiliaires les
prédateurs qu'on avait invité par nos
aménagements ont commencé à contrôler
les espèces nuisibles qui affectait nos
cultures de légumes jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
depuis plus de 40 ans les jardins du
grand portage sont ouverts au public
notre motivation à dionne et à moi c'est
d'essayer de faire apprécié leur règne
végétal par le plus grand monde on peut
pas défendre la nature si on n'aime pas
la nature et comment peut-on aimer la
nature bas il faut il y à être il faut
s'y promener il faut la contempler un
semencier
qu'est ce que ça fait de la vie un show
man she is it c'est comme un jardinier
d'une certaine façon parce que pour
produire des semences de légumes
il faut produire des légumes mais au
bout
du processus de culture il faut aller
chercher les semences à l'intérieur du
fruit ou sur la hampe florale
d'où vous est venue l'idée d'en faire un
métier
seulement c'est encore une fois c'est
grâce à une rencontre que j'ai pu
développer un intérêt pour la génétique
et la production de semences et le frère
armand sève n'y a qu'un claire st
viateur de joliette qui avait contribué
à la fondation du mouvement pour
l'agriculture biologique dans les années
soixante dix on s'est lié d'amitié pour
lui est incertain automne il nous a
invités à visiter son jardin et au mois
d'octobre il y avait 200 plants de
tomates de près de trois mètres de
hauteur chargés de fruits
j'ai été fasciné de voir la qualité de
ses plats et quand j'ai goûté à cette
peau mate loeb j'ai eu tout de suite le
même point de vue que lui c'est vraiment
un automate d'une succulente
exceptionnel pendant des années il
adaptera les semences de ce cultivar de
tomates qu'il baptisera savignac en
l'honneur de son mentor on peut par la
production de semences essayer
d'améliorer le comportement d'une ligne
et végétales et ça donne des résultats
trente cinq ans plus tard j'observe des
grosses grosses améliorations dans le
comportement des végétaux donges produit
laisse monde alors qu'on nous enjoint de
manger local yves gagnon remonte lui
jusqu'à la semence
les semences industriels peuvent être
produites en californie peuvent être
produites en espagne en israël alors que
quand on fait une production artisanale
ben moi les semences que je fais ici en
zone 4b à saint-didace belle sont
adaptés à mon environnement elles sont
adaptés à mon climat et quand on les
remet en terre bella clan qui en est
issu se reconnaît et bassons et dans son
environnement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ya trois grosses compagnies
agro chimique qui contrôle 60% de la
commercialisation des semences
sauf à être pas la diversité génétique
du tout au contraire souvent les
semences qui sont développés sont
adaptés à des pesticides que ces mêmes
compagnies produisent et commercialisent
donc quelque chose prétendants sur la
banc on mean la capacité naturelle des
végétaux a développé une certaine forme
d'immunité donc des capacités de se
défendre par e mail
[Musique]
avec cette mainmise de grandes
multinationales sur le vivant vienne un
autre inconvénient lié par contrat
les agriculteurs ne peuvent plus
conserver une partie de leurs semences
comme ils l'ont fait de tout temps un
producteur de blé pouvait déterminer que
dans une telle parcelle y avait eu un
rendement d'exception une bonne
résistance aux maladies à la verse et
ses dons qu'ils allaient conserver les
semences de cette parcelle là pour remy
l'année suivante et se faisant sur
plusieurs années on pouvait observer des
améliorations le patrimoine génétique
ses robes et pour s'adapter aux crises
alimentaires qui vont inévitablement
arriver moi je suis convaincu que la
diversité génétique voix est un outil
important pour nous permettre de
composer avec
avec cette problématique là mais il
gagne on voit dans l'engouement pour les
semences paysannes une lueur d'espoir
pour l'autonomie des agriculteurs au
lieu d'avoir une seule semence de blé
qui est produite par exemple dans un
état américain pour la moitié de la
planète
bell actuellement ce qui est en train de
se passer avec les petits semenciers
artisanaux comme nous il ya des semences
qui sont produites dans à peu près
toutes les régions du canada
c'est d'autant plus important d'avoir
des semences adaptées à nos écosystèmes
convient alors des changements
climatiques et ces changements là vous
vous les observez
qu'est ce que vous voyez ici quand on
est arrivé ici on avait du gel
systématiquement au début juin et à la
fée où souvent on avait un gel et si je
n'ai pas la fin et où il jouait au début
septembre donc on avait 16 ans angèle de
80 jours 90 au maximum aujourd'hui la
saison de culture sans ce gel est passé
de 80 jours à 120 à 130 jours
donc notre saison s'est métamorphosée
période de temps très très courte on
parle de 40 ans
ou si on a des extrêmes climatiques
cette année on a vraiment un très bon
exemple de cela on a eu un printemps
absolument exécrable joue direction de
pire printemps qu'on a connus depuis 40
ans avec canicule et gels tardifs aussi
sûr ça fait des variantes et les
végétaux ont beaucoup de difficultés à
composer avec une situation qui changent
de manière aussi extrême
[Musique]
il faut être préoccupé par ce qui se
passe
posh s'agit des climatiseurs il faut
arrêter d'émettre du carbone c'est
solène la solution alors on dit depuis
trente ans qu'il est moins simple qu'il
est moins 4 mai lors ses filles
on y attend donc il faut immédiatement
agir j'ai une petite fille de 20 mois
neymar aux écarts ça vient mais on tombe
en amour et le chevet le calcul à vos
vies jusqu'à 2100 à peu près ces avis 80
qu'elle surnomme en cave avoir en 2005
moi j'ai eu une très belle ville de
jbeil guerre du changement climatique
m'affecte un peu j'ai chaud un peu les
pelles et elle qu'elle sorte de monde à
voir voir alors moi il me reste 15 juin
en ville je dois m'occuper le plus
possible de sa vieille jurca lane vie
comme celle que j'ai eue
donc je dois essayer de travailler à
sensibiliser les gens à l'importance du
changement climatique
je veux m'impliquer et puis je dois
essayer de participer à cette mouvance
là pour essayer de freiner cette hausse
des températures pour que nos enfants et
nos petits enfants et une vie comme il
le mérite
[Musique]